Special Afferents
of the Head and
Neck Video 1 Olfaction
and Gustation
Or Smell and Taste
The following three
videos provide
a summary of the
special senses for
the head and neck.
Much of this information
is distilled from
chapters 8 and 10 of
Moore's Clinically
Oriented Anatomy. As
with previous lecture
videos, I recommend
focusing on the blue
pages slash blue boxes
in these chapters as
they will contain
the most clinically
relevant information
about these structures.
This lecture video
series completes our
trek through the 12
cranial nerves. We will
cover cranial nerves
1, 2, and 8, with brief
cameos from cranial
nerves 7, 9, and 10.
Today's video
covers the two most
underrepresented
senses in our body,
starting with cranial
nerve 1, olfactory.
This is the least
researched cranial
nerve, and the one
that is the least
valued in everyday
life. Humans just
don't emphasize
our sense of smell.
The structure
typically referred
to as the
olfactory nerve is
in fact the
olfactory stalk.
This structure is
comprised of the
olfactory tract
and olfactory bulb.
The olfactory nerve
is not a true nerve.
These structures
are anterior
extensions of the
forebrain that end in
multiple little
terminal nerves.
This is the human
olfactory bulb. Compared
to other animals
such as rats, dogs,
alligators, or even
dinosaurs such as
Tyrannosaurus rex,
it's pretty clear just
how much humans have
reduced our sense
of smell. The olfactory
bulbs rest above
the cribriform plate
of endocranium.
From the olfactory
bulbs, 10 or so nerves
descend down through
the cribriform plate of
the ethmoid bone. The
nerves traverse the
cheese-grater-like
cribriform plate until they
reach their destination
in the mucosa of the
superior-most portion
of the nasal passage.
Although we often
associate the nasal
passage with the
sense of smell,
only the superior
-most portion of the
nasal passage—a
relatively small part of
the entire nasal
passage—is capable of
olfaction. The remainder
of the nasal passage
is used to filter,
warm, and humidify
air before it enters
the lungs, and then
to reclaim that
water on the way out.
The three internal
swellings we see in
the nasal passage
are called conchi.
They are named
for their shape,
which resembles
a conch or conch.
Think of a conch
shell on the beach.
Only the superior
concha houses
olfactory epithelium.
This epithelium
extends over the
superior concha
and the adjoining
medial nasal wall.
This is where the
olfactory nerves end.
Formation of the
superior concha is
variable, with some
people not having
a superior concha
at all. Instead,
the olfactory nerves
are distributed
over the roof of
the nasal passage.
Air entering the
superior concal
portion of the
airway, referred
to as the
superior meatus,
slowly traverses the
olfactory epithelium.
Odorant molecules
get captured by the
olfactory mucosa,
transporting the
molecules to olfactory
receptor cells.
This triggers the
cells, depolarizing them
and sending the signal
back through the
cribriform plate and
into the olfactory
bulb where they synapse
with another specialized
group of cells,
called mitral cells.
These cells send
the olfactory signal
back to the rest of
the brain along two
different olfactory
striae, a lateral
and a medial stria.
The olfactory nerve
is the only cranial
nerve that directly
connects to the
cerebrum. All other
cranial nerves connect
from the brainstem.
Clinical correlate.
The most common
clinical case related
to the olfactory system
is anosmia, or the
inability to smell.
Anosmia can be
acquired from multiple
sources, including
damage to the
olfactory epithelium
itself or the
cribriform plate. In
many instances, there
is a congenital
component involved.
This pathology has
received more attention
recently, as anosmia
used to be a hallmark
of early variants of
the COVID-19 infection.
Anosmia largely affects
a person's quality
of life. People with
anosmia will comment on
food being less
appetizing. This is due to
the intimate connection
between smell and
taste, which we will
cover later in the video.
People suffering
from anosmia may find
themselves in urgent
care more often
due to accidental
food poisoning as the
lack of smell
receptors prevents them
from recognizing when
food has spoiled.
The second special
afferent in
this video is
taste, or gustation.
Taste is unique as it
is the only special
afferent to span
multiple cranial
nerves. The sense of
taste is conveyed to
the brain on cranial
nerves 7, 9, and 10.
Taste is the ability
to recognize chemical
signatures on items
that touch the tongue,
which is the main organ
for taste sensation.
The capacity to
taste also exists
on part of the oral
soft palate and
pharynx, but
these all pale in
comparison to what
we see on the tongue.
Gustation on the
tongue is made possible
due to numerous ridges
on the surface and
sides of the tongue
mucosa. These ridges
are called lingual
papillae. There are
four types of lingual
papillae, filiform,
foliate, fungiform,
and circumvalate.
Circumvalate papillae
are the least numerous,
with the typical
person having between
8 and 12 papillae.
In contrast,
filiform papillae
are extremely
numerous and cover
most of the tongue.
However, filiform
papillae are
also the only
lingual papillae
that lack taste
receptor cells.
Instead, these
papillae function in
gripping food items
with the tongue. The
taste-sensing
structures on the other
three papillae are
called taste buds.
Taste buds are a
collection of afferent
neurons that come
together to form a single
taste-sensing structure.
Each taste bud
has between 50 to
150 taste receptor
cells bundled together
to form a structure
that looks a bit like
a hand of bananas.
A single lingual papilla
may have hundreds
of taste buds across
its surface. There
are five recognized
taste categories.
Sweet, salty,
sour, bitter,
and umami, or savory.
Hold up a minute.
What about spicy food?
That's a taste, isn't it?
Though we often
associate spiciness with
food flavors, spice
is not a true taste.
There are no spice
receptors on the tongue.
Instead, spice
is conveyed back
to the brain
via these guys,
our nosoceptors.
Nosoceptors are our
pain receptor cells.
Spices, typically
from capsaicin,
irritate our mucosal
lining, and that pain
is relayed back to
the brain via our
nosoceptors. In
particular, our thermal
nosoceptors, hence why
spicy food feels hot.
The unique way
that individuals
interpret this pain
is what determines
a person's
spice tolerance.
This is also why you
can taste with your
eyes, nose, genitalia,
and **** region.
Theoretically, any
part of our body
that has nosocceptors
can taste spicy
food, though this
is often limited
to just parts that
contain mucosa.
So, not a true
taste category, but
still a fascinating
phenomenon. Alright,
back to taste buds.
Taste receptor cells
are sensitive to only
one of the five taste
types mentioned here.
However, the
distribution of taste
receptors within even a
single taste bud is such
that every part of
the tongue mucosa can
taste any of these
five taste categories.
Different nerves
convey taste to the
brain from different
parts of the tongue.
The posterior one
-third of the tongue
uses the glossopharyngeal
nerve, cranial
nerve 9, to convey
taste information.
A small portion of
the posterior part
of the tongue, as
well as bits of the
oral soft palate and
pharynx, have their
taste information
conveyed to the brain
via the vagus nerve,
cranial nerve 10.
By far the largest
contributor to gustation
is the facial nerve.
This nerve conveys
taste information to
the brain from the
anterior two-thirds of
the tongue via a special
branch of facial
called corda tympani.
We briefly covered
the course of
corda tympani in my
previous lecture.
The nerve travels
through the middle
ear cavity and
exits the skull
through the petro
-tympanic fissure.
From here, corda
tympani hitches a
ride with the lingual
nerve, cranial
nerve 5-3, to
reach the tongue.
As with the hypoglossal
nerve and the
cervical plexus,
even though both
lingual and
chordotimpany appear like
a single nerve at
this point, their
two epineural sheaths
remain separate.
So why is the
tongue this rich
tapestry of nerve
associations?
The answer has
everything to do with
how our tongue forms
embryologically.
The tongue starts
in the fourth
week as a series
of swellings from
the first four
pharyngeal arches.
Each pharyngeal arch
has a specific nerve
associated with it. As
the tongue develops,
it drags in contributions
from these four
different cranial
nerves. In the case
of chordotimpani, we can
see that the anterior
two-thirds of the
fully developed tongue
are covered by
trigeminal, not facial.
However, earlier
in development, the
facial nerve's
distribution was more
present thanks to
contributions of pharyngeal
arch 2 to the
developing tongue.
During this time, our
protochordotimpani
nerve splits off from
the protofacial nerve as
the pharyngeal arch
swellings are dragged,
the first pharyngeal
arch as the tongue forms.
Clinical correlate.
Taste is second only
to olfaction when
it comes to under
-representation in
medicine and research. The
biggest clinical
correlate associated with
gustation is agusia.
This is a loss of the
sense of taste, and
it often goes hand in
hand with anosmia.
Agusia has also seen a
relatively recent surge
in interest, as loss
of taste was another
factor commonly
associated with early
strains of a COVID-19
infection. Other ways
of acquiring agusia
include exposure to
toxic chemicals, illicit
drug use, or head
trauma, which can cause
a temporary or
permanent loss of taste.
The loss of a sense
of taste, as with the
loss of sense of smell,
can place a person
at risk for inadvertent
food poisoning as
they cannot taste food
that has gone bad.
Largely, agusia affects
the quality of life
for the patient as
the inability to taste
lowers hunger levels
and often leads to poor
nutrition as the
affected person may try
to compensate for a
weakened gustation by
substituting more salt
or sugar into their
food. Much like anosmia,
there are currently
few treatment options
available for agusia.
Smell and taste are
deeply intertwined
with one another. They
offer two different
means of analyzing
chemicals from
the environment, or
chemosensation. They
are also an example
of a coupled sense.
Coupled senses are
two or more senses
that work together
to perform a third
function. For olfaction
and gustation,
that third function is
the concept of flavor.
Although we typically
associate flavor with
just taste, true flavor
requires both the
sense of smell and the
sense of taste. It has
often been stated that
80% of flavor comes
from just the smell of
food alone, though as
far as I know there are
no real quantitative
measures behind that
statement. The importance
of smell in the
flavor of food can be
made obvious when a
person suffers from a
stuffy nose. Food eaten
during this time is often
considered bland and
pretty flavorless.
If you have used air
travel recently, then you
may have also noticed
that airplane food
is remarkably bland
despite its high salt and
sugar content. The
high altitude and heavy
air recirculation in
airplanes lowers the
ability to detect airborne
odorants, producing
a weakened sense of
flavor. You can test this
the next time you take
a trip on a flight
by holding on to some of
the snack food offered
to you on the plane
and tasting it some
10 to 20 minutes after
you have landed and
resettled your body.
The now grounded snack
items should taste
noticeably sweeter or saltier
compared to their
taste on the plane. The
coupling of smell and
taste occurs at multiple
sites of integration
in the brain,
including the thalamus
and orbitofrontal cortex.
You will learn more
about these structures
in neuroanatomy
next semester.
This brings us to
the end of video one.